hey it's ross matthews and this is
rapidfire ross where i ask questions too
fast for no reason
okay i'm going to hit you right now with
questions as fast as we can are you
ready
you played galinda right yeah okay what
character do you most relate to in
wicked i would say i must relate to
dr dilliman something bad
why
because he saw there was something not
good happening and you know how to tell
anybody and sometimes i have a hard time
telling them i understand but you seem
like the kind of person you can spot it
and you see something you say something
well i say it too nicely and then nobody
hears it understood what is your
favorite musical of all time gypsy
you presented the tonys i saw that you
presented with jake gyllenhaal i saw
that could i just get one word to
describe them up close it smells very
good that's a lot of words there's a lot
of words but good to know yeah
what's one role you've always wanted to
play in a musical i've always wanted to
play charity and sweet cherry oh you
think you will
i'd have to stretch but i'd love to
what about legally blonde do you have a
favorite quote
oh my god you guys
i love that quote
all right do blondes have more fun i
think so the vitamin d hits them even
stronger because you know it just gets
in your scalp i understood you know i
live in palm springs where we soak up
the sun all the time yeah baby all the
time but do you have the spf oh yes and
you know but i like to take my hat off
from time to time just to make sure i
get it they say you actually are
supposed to go in direct sunlight for
just a little bit together do they say
that well yeah i mean you should have
your sunscreen on but like take your hat
off just take your hat off just for a
little bit i live my life like the cool
caveman i'm like out of the sun covered
all the time i want to look like 40 when
i'm 90.
okay i'm obsessed with your performance
in impeachment bill and monica that if
you guys aren't watching you must you
are so phenomenal
in this role if you ever elected
president what's one law you would enact
like that i would change the voting laws
immediately everybody can vote all the
time usa usa yes hello oh that's the
first thing i would do hello
national holiday
i would also enact a happy hour every
day
yeah we all should sort of like time out
let's just have a happy hour on 5 30 and
then get back to it
do i have your vote yeah
all right that's rapidfire ross thanks
for playing my pleasure it's happy hour
gotta go
[Music]